hello my name is Kelly Brownell I'm the
director of the Rudd Center for Food
Policy and obesity at Yale University
before we begin today's podcast i would
like to invite you to visit our website
at www and a list of other podcasts that
we recorded with excellent guests who
have come to the Rudd center but today
I'm very happy to welcome mark bittman
noted author a journalist and of thinker
on issues of food and food policy mark
is the author of the minimalist column
for The New York Times has written a
best-selling and best selling food
cookbook called how to cook everything
has written a number of other books as
well and is a noted figure in the food
arena so mark welcome thanks very happy
to have you here and I know that you've
written about a controversial topic in
particular recently and that is the
possibility of taxing soda can we talk a
little bit about why you believe that's
important to do well I think that we
have to I think the bottom line is that
we have to try every single thing we can
to change the way most people in the
United States eat and I'm sure you've
done dozens of podcasts about what's
wrong with the way we eat and and its
really clear that it needs to be fixed
so there are a variety of things that
need to happen what's what's appealing
to me about the soda taxes does
primarily does two things one it
discourages the consumption of soda and
I'm sure we can get into why that's an
important thing but so it is not to put
too fine a point on on it evil and then
the second is it raises money to
encourage better eating in other arenas
so maybe we can use the money from the
soda tax well to further discourage the
eating of let's say bad foods or to
encourage or subsidized the eating of
good foods I mean in a nutshell so the
word evils pretty strong well I mean the
single there's a no all of this is
inarguable there is an obesity epidemic
emack in the United States half the
people in the country are either
overweight or obese and by the
projection is that by 2050 everybody
virtually everybody will be overweight
or obese obesity causes diseases in
particular diabetes which is
irreversible so how does one become
obese generally speaking by consuming
too many calories so what we want to do
is have people consume fewer calories
and in particular one would like them to
be consuming fewer useless calories soda
contains sugar or more specifically high
fructose corn syrup and a bunch of
additives that amount to nothing and so
it has calories that are considered
non-nutritive and so it is also the
single biggest calorie source in the
United States seven percent of Americans
calories come from soda which is to say
seven percent of our calories come from
a non-nutritive source now there are
things wrong with high fructose corn
syrup and there are things wrong with
sugar there are potential dangers in
those particular ingredients that may be
even worse than what I'm speaking about
but if we just take it at the absolute
bottom line that seven percent of our
calories come from this one source and
it's non-nutritive that makes it pretty
bad I think so I've heard you refer to
soda as worse than neutral what do you
mean by that worse than useless I mean
like I said well i mean it's useless i
mean it's a it's a it's an engineered
craving i mean we don't were not born
craving we may be born craving sweets
but we're not born craving sugar in
particular it has no nutritional value
but it's worse than that because in
being a major cause of obesity so it is
therefore a major cause of diabetes and
there are other men you work in this
field you know this as well or better
than I do but there there's evidence
that high fructose corn syrup causes
obesity more rapidly than sugar or even
fat there's evidence that high fructose
corn syrup can possibly trigger diabetes
just
from a single can of soda there's
evidence that liquid calories in liquid
form don't give you the kind of society
the calories in solid form do so you're
they don't even make you full so it for
for all of these reasons I think it the
it's not a stretch to say soda is the
tobacco of the 21st century tobacco
there was a smoking gun directly linking
tobacco to lung cancer and we didn't
take care of that perfectly but we
addressed that issue there is a smoking
gun linking obesity 2 diabetes and so it
is a major cause of obesity okay so the
call to reduce consumption of
sugar-sweetened beverages brings you a
lot of company World Health Organization
the Centers for Disease Control the US
Department of Agriculture the Institute
of Medicine they're very long list the
parties that do that but there are a lot
of ways one could approach it why not
just educate your way to that goal to
get people to consume less well it
doesn't seem to be working I mean I
could I could turn the tables and say
well what what are the other ways to
approach area has there been a decline
in soda consumption in recent years I
mean there has been some education is
there a decline in soda consumption I
don't see it there the ad campaign in
New York the famous pouring on the fat
ad campaign in New York City I don't
think that dented soda consumption in
New York at all what is I'm not all in
favor of education but you're countering
one of the biggest marketing budgets in
history so how much money is the Center
for Disease Control the USDA the
institute of medicine etc etc going to
put behind this certainly not the
hundreds of millions of dollars that
Pepsi and Coke or putting behind it so
what can we do to counter this you know
I don't I was going to say I don't like
taxes more than any more than anybody
else but in fact I'm probably less
against taxes and many other people but
this is something that I think will work
you know I know you're an advocate of
this so it's funny to be sitting here
saying that but i think that the soda
tax makes sense but it has to be a steep
soda tax or real soda tax not a penny
per can but a dime or even better a
quarter per can something that will with
[ __ ] people's ability to drink it
so the industry makes number of
arguments against this but one is that
we're creating a nanny state where
governments too involved in what we what
do you how do you respond to that I
don't know I would just look at I mean
the government is the ideally the
government is there to help us make
decisions and do things in a way that we
might not be able to otherwise so you
look at seatbelts I mean you look at
tobacco but you don't even have to look
at the backhoe you look at seatbelts
when I was 20 years old in 1970 no one
used seatbelts Christ didn't even really
even have seatbelts by the time I was 25
some people were using seatbelts and
cars were equipped by the time I was 30
the government was saying you have to
her seat belt in by the time I was 40
you would get a ticket if you weren't
wearing a seat belt and now the seatbelt
usage numbers are huge and they sell
they save tens of thousands of lives a
year is that nanny statism I don't think
that's 90 statism I think it's the
government saying we are here we are
seeing something that's beneficial to
the public health we're going to help
our citizens we're going to help our
citizens help themselves I mean to me
that's what government is therefore well
there many other examples of course like
requiring the children being immunized
before they start school clean air clean
water their number thing public health
things that get involved so that for
that matter water treatment right sewage
I mean these are all public health is
old nanny ism if you're going to say
that but individuals can Institute these
things individuals can of course decide
to drink less soda but there's some
evidence that so it is addictive there's
some evidence that sugar is addictive we
know that caffeine is addictive and
there's something of this just such a
thing as habit also people need help
changing their habits this is a bad
habit over with the tobacco thing is
obviously the prime example of the
government helping us to change that
habit so you wrote a key piece in the
new york times throughout the soda was
key but it was like I realize it was
important and then of course you've
spoken about this have you had what kind
of reaction have you had to do your
discussion of the soda tax well there
was a little bit of noise from the
American Beverage Association around the
times piece but really not much
I frankly the reactions been all
positive but I think I tend to speak to
people who believe the same thing I do
so so that that's it's hard to know how
much that's worth I don't see this I see
this as inevitable I think you have the
mayor Philadelphia proposing a two
pennies per ounce soda tax which is
higher than even what you've proposed
routinely which is one penny per ounce
which in itself means that means that
can cost a dollar 12 instead of a dollar
and a case of you know the amazing thing
is that a case of you can get a case of
12 cokes for 399 so that's about a
quarter of a can and that would go up to
those would go up to 37 cents a can with
a one penny per ounce then they go up to
50 state double in price with a two
pennies per ounce thing that is
significant that would cost a lot of
money and that would raise a lot of
money and I think if people you know
I've bought soda I've bought soda in 12
ounce boxes because it was so cheap I
felt like well why not have it around I
mean someone's going to want it so why
not have it if it were eight dollars
instead of four LS well fewer people
would buy it and that's a good thing
it's the consumption needs to be curbed
however that happens is fine with me i
think the tax probably makes more sense
than many other ideas than any other
idea i know of so one interesting issue
then becomes what do you do with the
money let's raise from a tax and so the
estimates are that you'd raise 150
billion dollars over ten years if you
had a penny per ounce tax on sugar
sweetened beverages so one could
potentially do a lot with that money now
of course if you use the tobacco
experience as a precedent then you're
not quite sure how government will use
it and some states would use it more
wisely than others but if you could
write a script what do you think would
be the ideal use of all my revenue well
I I think if i could write a script i
would use that money i would use that
money to make more money i would use i
mean i'd use that money for a big public
public health marketing campaign but i
would gear part of that public health
marketing
campaign to increase exactly those kinds
of taxes so I you know I know this is
even a sort of thin end of the wedge
thing and that's exactly what I'm
thinking and I would not mind seeing a
Fritos tax or a Cheetos tax and a
cheeseburger tax and a fast-food tax in
general and so on down the line my goal
my ultimate goal is to see people
cooking and eating real unprocessed
foods there needs to be an education
campaign around that but some people
need more than education some people
don't have the ability or the time to
cook for themselves and I'd like to see
you know i'd like to see public funded
cooking schools i think that having a
cooking core of people who can help
people cook for themselves learn how to
cook or even cook for other people i
think all of those things are fantastic
ideas these are really public health
measures I mean it's an it's again I can
understand why people would say well
this is nanny state and there's people
people should be able to take care of
themselves and so the fact that some
people may need more help than others
and the fact is these are public health
issues if we reduce its not just obesity
if we reduce our reliance on processed
food and junk food if we rely on
unprocessed foods and more plants than
animal products we will generally be a
healthier nation so it's not only going
to save us money in the long run we'll
make our taxes back because we'll be
spending less on other aspects of public
health like health care but will also
live healthier and longer lives which is
I mean that sort of a basic goal because
well that's a good point down thank you
so much for joining us divorce so our
guest today was author Mark Bittman from
the New York Times and author of
best-selling books including how to cook
everything I'm delighted you could join
us today and please visit our website at
www